i know you guys wanted us to cover this
and some of y'all got upset just know
like yo yo we got lives okay this man's
on tour i'm busy with other stuff we
can't always why are we not covering
this [ __ ] like i think i think
accountability i think
i think you guys think we filmed every
day we've been like once or twice a week
okay and we could feel for about two
weeks because he was gone so that's why
all right we'll just chill
all right let's see how y'all gotta
chill bro
recap recently dave chappelle released a
special on netflix and in that special
he made some jokes that
were transphobic a couple weeks back i
posted a video talking about my opinions
on the dave chappelle special and
apparently these people did not like it
he is a straight man not gay not trans
none of the above which i will say i do
think it would make a difference if he
was gay or trans you know what i mean i
feel like gay people can make jokes
about gay people trans people can make
jokes about trans people flame monroe
makes uh
comedy about lgbtq people and she's
getting flamed no pun intended all the
time
so
people are going to get offended no
matter what i'm not people i never said
that i had a problem with flame monroe
not all trans people think the same
that's fine i was just giving my
personal opinion that if you're trans
you can you know make whatever jokes you
want to make she's saying it's
acceptable for flame monroe because
she's a trans woman to make jokes about
trans people irrespective of what they
do whether they reinforce negative
stereotypes or not that's what she's
saying so i want you guys to remember
that and we'll keep watching that's just
my opinion
whenever i hear this stuff or it's like
only black folks can make jokes about
black folks white folks can make jokes
about white folks and women can only
make jokes about women and men can make
trips really
women can't make fun of men but this
whole thing like you can't make fun of
other groups why why not
and also to what degree do we want to do
this should poor people only be able to
make fun of poor people rich people rich
people no americans americans people
poor people can make fun of rich people
because they're punching up but
oppression cannot punch against the
oppressed yeah i'm not a fan of the
whole punch-up punch down stuff you know
what i mean if you want to go and make
fun of children make fun of children if
children make fun of you make fun of you
i don't people i i dislike it when
people gate keep
who can make jokes about who i won't lie
watching kids fall is pretty funny
especially when they're on ice you know
they stumble for a while and then
eventually they look so great that's not
really the kind of joke they were
talking about though dave didn't show a
video or laugh at a trans man falling he
laughed at our bodies
look at that big chisel joe man that big
thick joe broken neck he joked about how
he's on team turf do you know what a
turf is turf is an acronym
stands for trans-exclusionary radical
feminists i'm team jerk
a turf is a type of activist that
focuses on how trans women are actually
men and they're just pretending to hurt
women that's a funny thing to align with
that's that's just like a joke hey man
listen you want to do a joke and say
you're on team turtle i got no problem
you want to make a joke you say you want
team kkk you all got no problem go ahead
make it funny that's all
hey man i'm not going to say nobody can
not do any do it and even if it's
unfunny you know what i'm gonna say that
was pretty that sucked but just because
this stuff
is things that you would deem
unacceptable doesn't mean people can't
joke about it yes people could say
they're on team kkk and you could
probably find a funny bit just because
you can imagine that be funny doesn't
mean there's not people who can't do it
some of the most wild bits i've ever
heard were on topics that everyone
thought could never be funny right take
louis ck's bit on how good it feels to
diddle kids
right and the whole premise i'm not
going to give it away if you go watch it
it's one of his best bits ever you can
say you're on team turf and make it a
funny bit when i say that i don't think
that cis people should be able to joke
about trans people or you know men about
women blah blah blah i don't mean to say
that cis people can never mention trans
people or you know mentioned their
experience with trans people and joke
about that and you know maybe that was
my mistake maybe i did not articulate
that the best way he was laughing about
the fact that a trans woman was trans
literally that if he were to see a woman
with a penis that would be the funniest
thing ever and suddenly
a woman walks into the men's room that's
strange
and then she hikes your skirt up
and pulls a real live
meaty dick out
you know what's funny about this
sentence it's the word no no no no no no
no no it's not that's fine but what's
also funny is like hearing like a woman
her
she pulled out her that's what makes it
funny because it's a sentence that kind
of discombobulates you even if i can
grant you that she should be allowed in
those spaces that everything should be
fine with that but it doesn't change the
fact that inner subconscious a lot of us
see that and do find it funny because i
could be as progressive as i want right
i can be right all for gay rights and
other stuff i'm with them however
when we are passing legislation to fight
sodomy and homosexuality there are
something that will never see the light
of day in uganda
we have discovered that homosexuals are
trying to eat the poo poo of other men
and we have to ask ourselves is this
what barack obama wants to bring to our
country absolutely homophobic [ __ ]
hilarious even in a lot of darkness you
can find a lot of humor in there peep
game go ahead
if you
switch the joke
and
imagine a dude
like a frail dude
walking in the bathroom
and he's at the urinal stall yes all
right imagine some tiny dude like
andy dick
no pun intended
and he's like yo and this black guy
pulled up to me
and he was the same size as me
but he's pulled out his big huge meaty
dick and i was like what the [ __ ] it
could have been funny or what would have
been funnier if he had pulled out a
micro penis
imagine a big old buff dude looking like
he's coming from a set you know what i
mean i'm talking about like
blackzilla okay
timberlands kneepads everything ready
for a porno shows up and pulls out a
micropenis are we laughing at his body
undoubtedly there's an absurdity there
between the expectation of what we have
and what we're seeing that is funny to
people now of course what i personally
have an issue with is when people see
these kind of jokes and they say they
are harmful they are dangerous they are
hate speech i'm like whoa now we're
going to a different realm i'm not even
mad if you looked at and said i think
that's transphobic you can say that yes
you can say that right the same way
somebody can look at a joke and say
that's just racist i'm not mad at that
what i can't stand in a lot of this
rhetoric is like a lot of folks who see
like words or violence and this is
violence and they're saying it
contributes to a culture of violence
they're saying that trans women are
being killed these people are making
these jokes and they're linking these
things oftentimes caricatures
stereotypes and misconceptions that hurt
trans people they get our rights taken
away that get us beaten and murdered by
people whose only information on trans
people comes from people like dave
chappelle there are ways that you can
joke about trans people without making
the punchline of the joke the fact that
we're trans i can
but i don't have to that that's the
thing
that's the thing yes you're absolutely
right on that the same thing for black
people
you can make fun of black people without
making them fatter they're black you can
you don't have to it's not a half or
sometimes you know what's funny i'm not
gonna lie to you that whole like [ __ ]
in the dark and sometimes all you can
see in the teeth
corny repetitive but if it's done
creatively enough you can laugh at the
fact that someone's really i remember
the first time i heard dave chappelle
say oh look darkness falls everybody who
was he talking about charlie murphy
because he was so dark
you can make that [ __ ] funny you can
laugh about people's blackness the
tongue to their skin their large lips
they're whatever all of these things can
be funny provided they have the right
circumstance but what i will say is
really important this whole thing
just because they the person doesn't do
a good job with the joke it does not
mean it's inherently a problem just
because the joke is unfunny or you
demon's like yo it's not funny it's
hateful just because it's dead doesn't
mean it's a real issue but that joke
contributes to colorism in haiti
here's something that the late great
patrice o'neill said what we are
fighting for is not necessarily a joke
itself but the attempt yeah okay right
because good jokes and bad jokes funny
jokes and unfunny jokes they all come
from the same place in your brain all
right so people have to separate what's
funny what's not from what's right
because at the end of the day it doesn't
matter whether it's funny or not are
they trying if they are then cool you
can hate it you can say it's racist you
can say it's transphobic i don't care
but don't say it's harmful or it's
dangerous or it's contributing to
violence because then you have to make a
big leap right a dangerous sleep but
you'd have to make it and you'd have to
prove it and i reject that notion
wholesale like the trans experience is
funny even being somebody around the
trans experience funny tons of comedy
gold in that you know situation you
don't want to make fun of the fact that
somebody's trans and then
i don't know i don't know what it's just
you just said
caitlyn then you couldn't react okay
couldn't on any level be like oh my god
you know what the f on any level you
couldn't say that or you automatically
homophobic did you send your beard off
to you like oh my god that [ __ ] [ __ ] wow
dude came back a woman you're just
supposed to be like yes anyways
you know what's crazy is that joke is
pretty much identical to james spell
joke
it didn't talk about the penis but it
talked about literally changing your
physical appearance and making fun of
you for being trans no but penis is more
serious
is this like it's not a chin it's a
penis and the reason why he didn't say
all the stuff that dave chappelle was
saying was because he was on conan no he
couldn't cross that line he's literally
talking about the fact that we can't
make that comment and you couldn't react
when you couldn't on any level be like
oh my god you know what the f on any
level you couldn't say that are you
automatically homophobic so the example
that you used was of a comed and saying
there's so much taboo i can't say what
i'm thinking so he found the most pc way
to be like
she was a man and now
she's a woman and that's the thing is
that you you're kind of taking the joke
out of his context and just going on
what he said and not including the
context and that's very wrong to do that
but whenever you take away all
everything that was surrounding that
joke and just putting what was said and
that that's the example there like dave
mock's trans woman for literally just
having a penis and in my opinion this is
really comparable to white people making
jokes about the stereotypical features
that black people may have just like in
those racist jokes where people are
laughing at somebody being black or you
know the caricature of a black person
dave is making fun of trans people for
literally just being trans the same
thing goes for race or gender i think if
a black person wants to make jokes about
their struggles with you know being a
black person i think that's fine i think
if a woman wants to make a joke about
being a woman that's fine however i
don't think the opposite is true i don't
think it would be okay for a white
person to joke about a black person's
experience i don't think it'd be okay
for a man to joke about a woman's
experience and i also don't think it
would be okay for a cisgender person to
joke about a trans person's experience
so maybe i should quickly clarify what i
meant in that little segment when i see
that mentioned joke about women's
experience or why people shouldn't joke
about black people's experience i'm
referring to those jokes that perpetuate
discrimination perpetuate discrimination
so
i want you guys to peep something really
important this right earlier she said
she doesn't mind if flame monroe doesn't
flame around can make whatever jokes
according to her why because she's trans
so it's perfectly fine for trans people
to perpetuate uh anti-trans con jokes or
perpetuate trains um stereotypes or
racist stereotypes right whatever sorry
trans stereotypes but it's not okay for
anybody else to do it why that's the
next question you have to ask yourself
but because that person is living the
experience
okay but that doesn't change the fact
that the words are still harmful
just because a black person gets in fact
i would argue it is more harmful for
someone from your community to go over
there and perpetuate these things then
it's from other people yeah because they
confirm it like a donkey perm right and
you know so i don't understand the
argument that it's acceptable for us to
perpetuate these racist stereotypes but
not for them and that's why i said
earlier on that that's why flynn monroe
is getting cancelled because of that
because it is more harmful when it is
from your own community undoubtedly i
still think flame should do it but it's
not true that if she does she's not
going to be canceled or that it's not
harmful if i was to take your position
in your approach to this discussion you
really have to resort to attacking
another minority community to boost your
numbers ain't nobody trying to talk
about y'all that deeply you guys just
won't shut the [ __ ] up and you guys are
in every news article always trying to
cancel folks of course the reason why
folks talk about y'all is because you
guys put yourselves out there all the
time and then constantly demanding
change from everybody i could honestly
say up until like
maybe five six years ago the train stuff
wasn't that that common in terms of
stand-up comedy no then the pronoun
stuff happened listen
we laugh comedians is the news if you
look at comedy that did not age well
it's a reflection of not the kami in the
comedian but the era which he lived in
comedy reflects what's going on on a
day-to-day basis
he said that he's mad that we're
demanding change and then references the
bathroom bills in north carolina these
bathroom bills that he references are
discriminatory even dave chappelle
admitted that okay i'm not mad at you
guys for being out there and demanding
these changes that's not the point you
shouldn't say that wasn't about the
point what i said was the reason why
folks talk about it is because you guys
are in the news that's all you guys are
constantly asking folks and demanding
changes which you should be but don't be
surprised when you demand change from
everybody and people discuss the change
that you want to see whether you care if
it hurt my feelings is up to you i
really don't care if you care you don't
even like okay you're an [ __ ] i don't
care if you don't care
[Laughter]
that was perfect that was perfect that's
not how i think work but whatever yeah i
don't care if you care you [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't
care you got hurt can i just appreciate
there's something really weird about
watching someone react to you and you
seeing yourself at the same time yeah it
feels like a lot of inception i hate it
in a video
okay you can't be saying i'm a trans
person of course i got hurt and then
minutes before say i'm gonna give an
unbiased opinion no x-files
also just because you were hurt doesn't
mean the joke was me
or or that it's not because it's not
because the joke was not funny that it's
not a joke you just didn't think it was
funny which is fine listen comedy's
always funny until it's directed at you
and then it's oppressive comedy is just
like a drunk uncle like christmas it's
funny until he touches you
hmm
yeah that's interesting yeah just
because you were hurt doesn't mean the
joke was mean just because you didn't
think it was funny doesn't mean it
wasn't a joke it's just jokes most happy
about the new policy these people so
yeah i'm gonna
buy a plow man i'm gonna plant that corn
i'm gonna get a job there barack obama
i'm the president of ploughing that head
you
crowders gonna crown her wow these guys
are so cringy these guys are
unbelievably cringing and you know their
undertones are so apparent it's crazy to
me oh look at that big chisel jawline
that big thick joe rogan is that a dude
here they come in with such ignorance
right and then they use these kind of
like stereotypical character characters
right pretty much doing blackface it's
it is it's black face not the black face
that's what it is and they're laughing
about it and it's just like okay that's
how you roll it's cool it's just jokes
guys okay wow cool
cool story you guys think that's humor
if you think that's trying to be funny
cool story we can't use a veil of humor
to do say this kind of stuff and always
be like it's just comedy we know the
difference most smart people know the
difference okay i feel like there's a
cut there
what's the second one
the video all right
it's just like okay that's how you roll
it's cool i don't get mad i don't get
upset i just peep game and i'm like i
know how it you alright i said i don't
get mad i don't get upset i just peep
game like is that how you roll cool
very important yeah very important i'll
tell you why i know she cut it out
that's her choice i'm not gonna get mad
maybe she's the editing error i don't
know but and and editing eric i don't
know you're good you know what cause you
you give her you that's not an error
mind you
i play a clip of him doing yellow face
this week the mystical age-old culture
of china
[Music]
listen okay
you are allowed to look at somebody and
this is my personal thing and say i
don't think they're trying humor
that's okay you can look at somebody and
say i think what they're doing is
transphobic that's okay you can look at
somebody and say i think they're using
the veil of humor to spread their race
ideology or their transphobicality and
that's okay i don't want to cancel steve
you want to cancel steve i've never said
that i've never said that i actually
said in the video uh oh is that how you
move okay i keep gaming and i keep it
pushing because here's the thing when i
said that yeah i did it just wasn't
including her video but it's okay okay
it's okay when i see someone doing stuff
like that you know what i do i'm keeping
pushing people we go to comedy shows all
the time yup you'll see people there go
up and do [ __ ] on stage you're like oh
boy
what'd you say
but you know what they even though they
may be doing an entirely racist set you
know what we do
hey man keep it pushing
that we we saw what that was but
whatever that's it i didn't come out
here and say this stuff is violence i
didn't say it's harmful i didn't say
dangerous actually i i spoke to her and
that's what i said i said oh by those
stuff the difference is that we're not
trying to cancel him and then she
replied well if i didn't i never tried
to cancel him i'm not i'm not talking
about you
but the people are trying to cancel them
and we're not trying to cancel nobody we
said in the video keep it pushing
keep on going we're not trying we're
saying that's that do whatever you do i
don't even think that she was trying to
cancel david my issue what she said is
that what his stuff is saying is
dangerous it's harmful yeah right or it
contributes to violence or whatever
that's the issue i have okay regardless
of whether or not my feelings were hurt
though there are a few arcs throughout
the special that i feel are potentially
dangerous to the progress of the trans
community playing into that cognitive
dissonance that some may feel when they
don't understand a trans feminine
identity allows dave to play into those
caricatures or those stereotypes or the
misconceptions that so many are familiar
with caricatures stereotypes and
misconceptions that hurt trans people
that get our rights taken away that get
us beaten and murdered by people whose
only information on trans people comes
from people like dave chappelle who
mocks trans people's experiences and
laughs at their bodies wait but it was
just a joke that doesn't mean he's
racist they say crowder might as well
just do blackface if he's gonna be
making jokes like that well i say that
dave might as well call us all men oh
wait they can say that stephen crowder's
jokes are just racism under a veil of
humor but when i say that dave
chappelle's jokes are just transphobia
under a veil of humor i'm being
ridiculous the lgbts are at it again
trying to cancel everybody it seems to
me that you both really do understand
the concept i really just wish you had
listened to my whole video he complains
about the increase of attacks on asian
americans then compares black people
beating up asians to his immune system
fighting off the covet virus playing
into the whole myth of kovit being this
asian disease
which is quite literally the reason that
hate crimes against asian americans has
gone up
that's a funny ass joke that's a funny
ass joke
that's funny but again if you don't like
it you don't have to like it
you don't have to like it stephen
crowder has a lot of fans that video
that you cited has a lot of views and
i'm sure that a lot of people thought
the jokes that he was making were
hilarious and that's okay
you know what if you go watch steven
crowder and say i think his jokes are
hilarious you know what i would say okay
do you watch amy schumer and that
dumpster fire of a comedy special that
she has and you think that shit's funny
you know what i say okay even if i think
you got poor taste even i think your top
i don't care
you should be allowed to watch whatever
the [ __ ] you want i do not give a [ __ ] i
don't like tough stephen crowder's
conservative violence against black i
don't say that [ __ ] because i don't
believe that
my personal opinion of stephen crowder
is my own i don't posing on anybody i
don't tell people should think this way
nor do i think he should be removed from
platforms so
this is i think the misconception that
exists
i've maintained this stance from the
start
i think you can do racist commentary
either you could do racist jokes
transphobic jokes i've even said in a
different video
i said you know what remember that that
that trans woman who was saying a bunch
of things that were racist
the the one who was against dave
chappelle
oh yeah
and what did i say in that video that
[ __ ] was fun that [ __ ] was funny
incredibly right i thought that was
funny and you know what i also said i
also said and it's okay if somebody else
looks at what i thought was funny and
said that's just racist yeah that
mexican piss blonde miss piggy looking
[ __ ] the delivery of that is amazing
hey listen you know
some people arrest
and some people are funny racist yes you
know listen
but if it's sprinkled in with some
creativity i can at least appreciate the
artistry
now the comic in me looks at this and
laughs because i think it's creatively
done it's funny it's not tacky right
that's me though that's me you can look
at it and be as outraged as you want and
you're completely justified you're
justified in your personal opinion
right what i said was like man even if
that's just braces if it's done with a
bit of creativity i would i could
appreciate that wasn't it that was there
you know that was there was it was a
swag i thought it was funny but i could
also acknowledge that yo that [ __ ] was
hella racist i look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] got a fat ass looking like a [ __ ]
i thought that [ __ ] was funny hey man
well i told you this story before but i
mean the first time i heard the word
doon [ __ ] referring to an air person i i
i almost cried laughing
because [ __ ] up but just thinking of
sand dunes and laura coons
what that's funny stop stop what stop
stop
[ __ ]
oh
i don't care nobody i think a lot of
slurs are funny that's me though and if
you disagree that's okay
guys i think if you could take away
anything from this video is that people
should be able to laugh about what they
want to laugh about hate what they want
to hate discuss and criticize what they
want to discuss but when you equate
jokes to being very dangerous when you
say that they could cause harm or
violence then we start to go in a
different place because what i send
another video which is what i was really
centered about in this whole dave
chappelle thing is like when you say
words or violence
or close to that you are saying that we
should take a different type of action
for these words and i just personally
disagree with that
that's exactly what you're doing with
dave chappelle you don't have to like
people do blackface it doesn't mean that
they're a racist this isn't about
whether or not i like the special like
come on this special in combination with
dave's other specials where he talks
about trans people and laughs at our
bodies and all the other media laughing
at trans people including me be abbey
and preaches videos you know talking
about how trans people are doing
whatever whatever that all of these
things are informing people's
perceptions of trans people i think one
of the big mistakes that people made
when it comes to stand-up comedy and
this is my personal take on it folks you
really disagree
when i go to see comedy shows i don't
think oh my god this box about to spit
some truth you want to know why
because in an effort to make a joke and
make punchlines comedians lie they omit
details they stretch things out comedy
is often about exaggeration so anybody
who goes to that thing and thinks
they're going to see cnn well [ __ ]
cena's a terrible example but real
journalism or some [ __ ] you're making a
big mistake and i feel that way about
dave chappelle i don't watch dave
chappelle like man [ __ ] what a
bastion of truth and and facts
dave chappelle's making like crazy
similes and like metaphors between like
asians and the it's nonsensical but it's
funny and it's hilarious when it is the
baby joke he says y'all get mad about
the baby shooting some dude you don't
get mad about the baby shooting some
dude walmart but he makes anti-gay
remark you want to cancel he admitted
the fact that he was like shooting into
self-defense yes self-defense right so
so i think there's a big mistake that
the public is making when they're
watching these specials and they're like
damn that's some facts that's true it's
like guys they're admitting and lying to
you sorry let me rephrase they're not
lying this is storytelling yes
the things that happened to slick rick
maybe didn't happen to slick rick yes uh
same thing as hip-hop and stuff like
that you know
it's a manipulation of what real life is
so yeah
i liked her video i thought it was a
good response we disagree and that's
okay
guys don't don't be out here leaving
wild comments some of you guys yeah that
that being said you got yeah you
disagree with her critiquing but y'all
y'all be leaving crazy yeah stupid for
real for that if that's what you do
you could you can you can unsubscribe
for real that's not that's not the point
of all this the point is out of the
conversation so if you go if we talk
about someone and anybody we talk about
on the
the the the channel
we do a video and we talk about anybody
no matter where they're from no matter
what what their gender or whatever where
they're from and you disagree with this
and you go out there
and you you you go and you trip that's
just wow yeah we're not rocking with
that so just want to say that yeah as
far as like informing people's opinions
you know that's what the thing i wanted
to say you know what i think you know
what happened what you know what
happened what happened with people's
mind in in in reality is really when a
wild trevor noah had appeared when they
used comedy to inform people in their
disgorge and even then there was a lot
of facts that were omitted just for the
funny but they really showed you the
late night shows and stuff like that
a lot of things were admitted to just
for the fun even in those shows i know
there's some things that are omitted
just for the funny uh whether it's
trevor noah whether it's jay leno uh
whether it's you know it was doing all
these bits for comedy it was really more
comedy informative and then it kind of
got really blurry in murky water i'm
gonna say this
i don't even think it's comics and
people like that's fault that the folks
are being confronted
but you know she's saying you guys are
informing folks
it's not like a conscious choice is
necessarily what has happened is that
folks have lost so much trouble in
public media in a lot of their public uh
um they lost so much trust in public
officials in regards to the dialogue
surrounding this stuff that they've
turned to [ __ ] comments
you know what i mean that's a problem
like people would be mad at me i'll give
you a people get mad like oh uh your
facts were unright about this case i'm
like yeah probably do you think i got
researchers do you think i'm out here
like googling all these stories you just
read them off and go quick
if i'm wrong listen i [ __ ] it up
that's on me but if you think that i
have like the same journalistic
integrity as a bunch of media outlets
you are bugging i will exaggerate things
and have a laugh so i'm going to tell
this to you guys the viewers and i'll
make this a big old disclaimer guys
don't come here to get your set of facts
about every single case maybe we'll
rattle off we'll try to be accurate in
some regards but if you are expecting
that high level of accuracy from us you
are [ __ ] up big time you should not
be coming to this channel to get your
facts about national news stories do you
get your facts from the barber shops
no okay it's it's the same thing hey
okay we talk about a subject and we
think about it we're not experts not at
all no no but we try to do a minimum of
research you know to not look like
complete foods and then we add a whole
lot of layered comedy because that's
what we do
but dude and also the third and last
thing is like guys
i think some of you don't know comedy or
don't understand it
most jokes
most humor most comedians they reinforce
negative stereotypes about people
through their jokes
yes
i don't even think that's a bad thing
but they do how many times have you
heard black folks go up on stage and
reinforce negative stereotypes about
black community every show i go to they
do that white folks about themselves
women about women they all reinforce
these negative stereotypes
and i don't necessarily think it's wrong
i know that sounds [ __ ] up in in a
discussion sense to say that
but if you go to comedy they do it all
the time so unless you want to revamp
all of comedy
we're gonna have to have a bigger
discussion that's what you're trying to
do but i don't know a single community
let's go out there and play on negative
stereotypes of a group they all do that
is am i wrong no no how many times
you've seen a black folk go up there and
talk about his big or how like he's also
afraid of black people sometimes right
women talking about the fact like you
know what i want a man to take care of
me uh my vagina vagina vagina
how many times
you know what women are not funny that's
women say that all the time
or dudes talking about the fact that
yeah well child predator like listen
i see it all the time pause what
yeah
yeah yeah i've heard of white dudes yeah
white dude's wild yeah
no boundaries
i've heard that yeah yeah i've heard
everything anyways i don't want to keep
this video going for too long but let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below what do you guys think about all
this stuff